- While I was traveling in New England
I found myself surrounded by people.
I hadn't been surrounded by
people for a very long time
and it felt weird, very weird, not least
because there's a pandemic
and there's a virus.
And it just was like, is this okay?
Luckily we were following all the state
and local guidelines, being smart,
but I found myself going through
this really weird mind process.
First being scared that
I was around people
and then being like, oh,
but I'm wearing a mask
and so it's probably fine.
I'm wearing a mask, mask to protect me,
but then being like, but
do masks actually work?
Didn't the CDC and WHO
come out and say like,
don't buy masks, masks aren't
the most important thing here.
Which was really annoying that they
then reversed their position.
Anyway it got me just thinking,
what does a mask actually do?
And is it actually protecting me
when I am around other people?
And I did what I always
do when this sort of thing
comes up and I went on a deep dive.
- Put surgical masks on.
- And I want to explain to
you four major takeaways
I've had about masks.
By the way, this really cool
green mask that I'm wearing
and a bunch of other ones
that you'll see me wearing
in this video come from
my friends over at BioSkin
who make really nice, comfortable masks
that are breathable and wonderful
and I'm gonna talk about them later.
For now let's talk about
the science of masks.
Takeaway number one:
your breath is kind of
like a rocking chair.
- [Man] Ignition.
- Bear with me on this one.
I promise it will make sense.
Watch this guy sneeze.
It's kind of gross, but this
process is like a rocket ship
for a virus who wants to
escape the orbit of your body,
make it out into space
and land in the orbit
of somebody else's body
through this rocket ship,
these respiratory droplets,
sometimes that stuff lands
on surfaces like a doorknob
and you touch that surface
and that's how it makes
it into your world.
Hence the mantra we've
heard a million times.
But as we got into this virus,
more and more scientists
started to study how the
virus actually moves around
and they started to say
with a loud megaphone
as loudly as they could,
the virus doesn't just
spread through droplets.
It also spreads through aerosols.
And all of us are like,
what the hell are aerosols?
And the scientists are like,
aerosols are just like the rocket ship,
but they're actually more
like that little capsule
that always breaks off of the rocket ship
when all of the fuel
parts of the rocket ship
fall back down to earth.
This little capsule keeps
flying out into space,
it's way smaller and it's just floating,
not subject to gravity.
Okay so back to this guy,
he's not even sneezing now
he's just talking or
breathing and all of this
is the aerosols that
are emitting out of him,
propelled in a specific direction.
It turns out that even
after the droplets fall
to the ground and onto surfaces,
the virus can stay in their little hatch,
these little air cells
and can float around
never falling to the ground.
This is really important
in understanding masks
and I will explain why in a minute,
but first we have to unpack
a second big takeaway
I've learned while looking into masks,
which is that number two:
the less virus you get,
the less sick you get.
This is what I think actually
most people get wrong about the virus
and it's actually something
that I did not understand
until I delved into the science here.
- Still trying to noodle over
what the implications of
these findings are for masks
and which type of masks one needs.
- I'd always thought that
if you catch the virus,
you're gonna get sick and how sick you get
depends on how good your immune system is.
It turns out that's not the case.
COVID-19 the disease and all viruses
and their effects are not binary.
It's not that you just get
them or you don't get them.
You can get really bad
symptoms, sometimes deadly,
and then you can have really mild symptoms
and you can even have it
with zero symptoms at all.
And one major thing that determines
how bad those symptoms
are, is your viral load.
How much of the virus gets into your body?
If a really small amount gets in,
it's likely that your symptoms
will be very, very low.
The more virus you get exposed to
the worst your sickness is,
this isn't actually a new concept.
This is something they've
known since the thirties.
I guess I didn't know it
and so I always figured
it's an on or off switch.
You either get it or you don't
and that's just not the case.
So yeah, it's a pretty
simple thing to understand.
I mean, you could go sit through
the hour and a half lecture
that I did from University of California,
or you could even dive into
the studies that they did
where they put literal masks on hamsters,
or you could just take it from me.
The less virus you get,
the less sick you get.
Okay so we have these
two pieces of the puzzle.
Number one, the virus can
break away from the droplets
and turn into aerosols
and float through the air
and get into your body.
And number two, the more virus
you get, the sicker you get.
Okay, let's put those two together
to figure out what masks actually do.
So number three, what masks actually do.
Once you put on your
mask, something happens
to everything coming out of your mouth.
Let's go back to our space
analogy for a second.
Putting on your mask is like increasing
the gravitational force
of your proverbial planet.
Imagine how hard it would
be for a rocket ship
to escape Earth's gravity
and get into space
if the gravity were five
or 10 times more intense.
So what a mask actually
does is it just increases
the gravity of your proverbial planet,
makes it a lot harder
for something to launch
from you into the world.
Lots of those droplets
get caught in the mask
so that stops them from even
escaping in the first place.
But the ones that do
escape and the aerosols
that escape from them and
have way less momentum,
they slow down the trajectory.
They create different currents and eddies
that keep them in your sphere.
So if you're infected and the virus
gets out of your body in
one of these aerosols,
it's much less likely to spread
to the people around you.
It's just like you have
a bunch more gravity.
You can see this with this
aerosol photography technique.
The person with the mask is
talking just like the person
without, their aerosols
are still escaping,
but they get slowed down
and they stay within the
orbit of the speaker,
as opposed to getting
sprayed out into the world.
Masks help direct the
particles in aerosols
that make it out of your breath
when you are talking or
coughing or sneezing.
So does this mean that you
should only wear a mask
if you are sick and you
have virus to project out
into the world?
Which is sort of what
they told us at first.
Let's be honest.
No, it turns out there is
science now that shows us
what masks do to people
who are not infected.
Let's talk about that
second piece of the puzzle
that I discovered,
which is the more virus you
get, the sicker you get.
Inevitably, some virus
from a droplet or aerosol
will make it out of someone's mask.
Even if they have a really good
mask on some will come out,
let's say you're nearby when that happens.
If you are wearing a mask,
there's no way that your
mask is going to filter out
all of those aerosols and
all of those particles,
those particles are too small,
they'll slip through your mask,
but if you are wearing
a mask, inevitably some
of those particles will get blocked
leading to less virus
getting into your body,
which can actually mean
way less severe symptoms,
which could in some
cases mean saving a life.
Even if it's just 50% that gets blocked,
that could have a major
effect on how sick you get.
In addition masks protect me from myself.
I tend to touch my face
like a lot of humans
do just subconsciously.
When you're wearing a mask,
you don't actually have access
to the vital parts of your
face that could let virus in.
So if you're touching
doorknobs or other surfaces
that are communal,
you suddenly have a
blockade from yourself,
which leads me to my last
and most important point,
which is that the math of masks is insane.
- You really better wear a mask.
- So quick recap: masks
make the proverbial gravity
around your proverbial
planet more intense,
so that it's much harder for things
to escape your orbit and for
the wearer who is non-infected,
it helps stop some particles
from getting into your system
leading to a smaller viral
dose, leading to less symptoms.
So imagine if all of these
forces come together,
you're in a public space and
everyone is wearing a mask.
Everyone is getting the
gravitational effect.
They're getting the filtering effect.
They're getting the don't
touch my face effect all
for themselves and for each other,
when this happens
something magical occurs.
Aatish Bhatia and Minute
Physics did a collaboration
on this to unpack the
probability math that occurs
when everyone wears a mask.
- [Teacher] Masks are also
complicated because they fly
in the face of our mathematical intuition.
- What they show is that
there's this multiplier effect
that when everyone is wearing a mask,
the probabilities of transmission
go down dramatically,
more than you would ever expect.
This helps me understand a major question
I had while I've been
in the COVID-19 data.
Mainly when I was working
on the New York Times piece,
I was looking at all this
data, especially in Asia,
a lot of these countries who
are used to wearing masks
like Taiwan or China or Vietnam
had really low death rates,
even if they had high cases
and that's because a lot
of people wore masks.
And so people who did transmit the virus
in these crowded places
got less dose of it
and became less sick and fewer
people died because of it.
Wearing masks truly does save lives.
And here in the United States,
if we had taken this seriously
and really had solid leadership
on wearing masks 100%,
we probably could have
saved a lot of lives.
So masks are here to stay
for the foreseeable future,
which is sort of waking me up
to the fact that I need a
comfortable, effective mask.
I don't really have one.
I sort of use these like homemade masks.
Don't really do the
trick for long-term use,
which is why I'm excited to be partnering
with my friends at BioSkin.
This is a company from my hometown.
I actually grew up working at this place.
They're a company who has
focused on materials and fabrics
and creating technical
and breathable fabrics
for sports bracing and
they've helped innovate
in that space and they've created a mask
that is breathable and
incredibly comfortable
and comes in loads of different designs.
They've run studies on this to find fabric
that is breathable, but
also effective in filtering.
And I got to tell you,
I'm very happy with the
design, the breathability.
I find myself being able
to wear it for long amounts
of time and not feeling
like I want to take it off,
which is sort of a dangerous thing
when you want to take off your mask.
So they're safe and they're
snug and they're durable.
They're machine washable.
They have a little metal thing on the nose
which helps keep a really
tight seal around the nose.
Very important.
And they come in these awesome three packs
that are affordable and durable.
BioSkin is offering a 10%
discount to my audience.
If you go to bioskin.com/johnnyharris
and enter the promo code
johnnyharris you'll get 10% off.
I 100% recommend these.
I know this company really well.
I've known them for years and I can vouch
for the quality of this product.
So thank you BioSkin for
supporting this channel.
Thank you all for watching
and wear your mask.
Oh, and P.S, they also
have kids masks too,
which is really cool.
So I have kids and, okay bye.